Hó kênh Áng dân dự ra y ra đã xây dự kêu chế phân loại các khu gia thành bài nhóm,
gồm thân thiện chung lập và thú định, nhằm kiểm sống hoạt động và tại quay biển học mốt,
tuyến hàng hai quan trọng của thế giới.
Theo đau tổ thuyền tự kêu gia thân thiện được phép đi lại tự giòn,
chung kỳ cái nước chung lập phải trả phi cào để được lúc thông.
Được với nhóm thú định, chung đau có Mỹ và một giữ khu gia phương tay,
y ra an áp dụng lận cấm đi qua yêu bình này.
Môn tiên từ Áng dân dự ra cũng cho biết,
tế ra an cũng cho phép tổ chưởng hàng vệnh trở nhân đạo và hàng ngoa tiết yếu được lúc thông.
Đồng thời để xuất khu trẻ đi lại an toàn có thu phí,
đối với các chuyến tổ thương mại.
Chúc khi đó, một số chuyên gia pháp để có thể hiện đệnh.
Đó tóc sống của mình pháp hàng chế và thu phí tại yêu bình hôm mốt,
có thể nhật lại với mình tắt tự sòn hành hành.
Đồng thời này của y ra an dễ ra chung bối cảnh,
cánh thằng khu vực trưa có số hiệu hạnh nhật,
và đang quý ra như tất động nhất định,
và với chuyển công ấn nước và thương mại tôn gão.